[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonne année également de
la part de toute l'équipe d' espace
autochtone en direct alors je m'appelle
anne-marie yvan je vous reçois comme à
chaque vendredi d'ailleurs pour ce
facebook live on commence l'année 2019
en fait de belle manière parce qu'on va
parler des langues autochtones
c'est l'année internationale des langues
autochtones s'était déclarée par les
nations unies ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle parce que ça va leur permettre
je l'espère de prendre beaucoup de place
tout au long de l'année et au delà parce
que comme vous allez l'entendre dans
notre conversation les langues
autochtones vivent des moments
difficiles
alors pour en parler plusieurs personnes
autour du plateau il est complet donc je
commence avec tout de suite à ma droite
philippe charles enfilé charland bonjour
vous êtes oui quoi le pire c'est que je
les écris en temps je veux dire pour
tout le monde vous êtes professeur
d'abbé naquit jeu qui n'a ici dans le
centre du québec un collège autochtone
depuis déjà un certain temps vous n'êtes
pas autochtone mais vous enseignez la
benaki tout un exploit
nous allons en parler parce que c'est
une langue qui vit des moments très très
difficiles et donc vraiment ce que vous
faites c'est assez extraordinaire
merci bonjour merci auteur compositeur
interprète non autochtone mais vous
apprenez linou oui de l'automne mais
depuis l'automne twin passage à peine
voilée ou le vous lui apprenez à
l'université de montréal avec une
excellente preuve d'ailleurs il est homo
l'oeil qui enseignent lino à plusieurs
endroits dont l'université de montréal
quick a brillé colonna les alors gabriel
paul qui est une journaliste qui passe
ce régulièrement par espace autochtone
et qui étudie aussi en sciences
politiques citées exactement ça oui et
vous aussi gabriel vous étudiez linou
avec yvette mollo nuit exactement le
même cours que julie marcy cet automne
voilà alors vous vous avez commencé en
fait là vous êtes au début vous avez
décidé de reprendre tout à zéro l'on
célèbre tout à fait je recommence à zéro
exactement on va pouvoir donc parler de
ce que vous étudiez
pourquoi vous le faites charles bako
robertson notre chroniqueur coup et
charles charles qui est in ou aussi qui
n'étudient pas l'hymne ou non qui ne
parlent pas qu'un peu je le parle très
peu
qui a envie de la prendre éventuellement
ou hépatiques ça serait quelque chose
qui qui qui ne pourrait être utile aux
autres au niveau des arts au niveau du
partage la culture inc
et puis ellis queen ou nasa coûteux
parce que ellis vous êtes notre
chroniqueuse régulière aussi vous
dirigez le site regard sur l'arctique et
vous apprenez les outils tout depuis
déjà plusieurs années puis se fait
depuis dix ans depuis que le projet de
regard sur l'afrique été mis sur pied du
canadien national et qui se fait dix ans
que je fais tous les efforts pour
apprendre la langue nouvelle comme il
faut et ça avance bien
oui mais on va peut-être parler de sa
visée les difficultés sa maîtresse aussi
de voir l'expérience des hôtes mais je
continue je continue alors je le disais
c'est l'année internationale des langues
autochtones ya six ans langues
autochtones à travers le monde
la majorité ne rompt pas une vie belle à
long terme
et ça c'est la réalité aussi des langues
autochtones au canada y en a à peu près
70 sont des autochtones au canada la
majorité parle et en colombie
britannique
là aussi il ya énormément de difficultés
au québec sur les onze langues
autochtones en fait il ne s'en parle
plus aux high heels en parle quoi
maintenant trois quatre cinq encore
assez régulièrement mais la peña qui ne
fait pas partie des langues autochtones
qui ont de grandes chances de survie à
long terme philippe bas deux au départ
les abénakis open très forte population
très nombreuse je ne savais pas beaucoup
et puis comme la langue un peu disparu
de 2
la tête de l' usage courant sauf que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de ramener
la langue à l'avant plan parce
qu'autrement ailleurs quand une
population de dix mille personnes
s'étaient plus de locuteurs possible
juste avec ce concept de mini 2700
population c'est pas très nombreux il y
en a beaucoup qui sont aux etats unis
aussi donc ça limite beaucoup plus la
possibilité d'extension et aux etats
unis c'est la même chose là il n'ya
presque plus de locuteurs et disons que
le bassin est encore plus fermé aux
états unis pourquoi vous avez choisi
déjà d'apprendre la binah qui est
ensuite de l'enseigné séparant des choix
c'est des situations qui sont pro 2
vitesse 1 suite d'événements qui sont
déroulés en fait c'est au début des
fêtes au siècle passé j'ai commencé une
thérapie j'ai commencé à chercher pour
avoir un suivre un cours de langue
autochtone qu'elles tombent autour de
montréal et il n'y avait rien
disponibles et variés à l'université
avait rien nulle part la seule la seule
langue avec disponibles c'était la bonne
équipe c'était aussi c'était pas trop
loin de chez moi donc j'ai décidé de les
faire des coupes j'ai été accueilli par
une dame monique balotelli qui donnait
des cours déjà à l'époque puis qui m'a
donné la piqûre de la benakis je peux
dire ça comme ça
puis au fil du temps mais les
circonstances ont fait que la décide
prendre sa retraite de l'enseignement
qui se passait toutefois donner de cours
soukouna il est suivi par des
autochtones et non autochtones
celui que je donne à odanak celui que
j'ai un enfant que j'ai repris le
premier que j'ai commencé ce que j'ai
repris de monique en fait on sent que 10
personnes qui vont venir chaque semaine
dépassement la raison pourquoi elles
veulent suivre des cours d'un dîner
regard nous parce que ce sont des
abénakis en oxyde par intérêt personnel
qui veulent suivre un cours de la terre
que je suis divertissant je ne sais pas
et en plus sur quoi vous vous basez pour
enseigner la benaki qu'est ce que vous
avez comme référence en fait on a en
fait que contrairement à d'autres
langues
quand même certaines choses décrite en
abénakis il ya des textes écrits en
abénakis par des abénakis des efforts
quand effet même au 19e siècle par des
abénakis parce que l'école de jeux
étaient faits on a déjà enseigné en
abénakis le primaire swaziland abénakis
au 19e siècle donc un peu mis un peu de
texte c'est un peu d'outils qu'on peut
se servir
puis quelques dictionnaires dont coop
iga gauche à droite pour monter quelque
chose qui est qui et qui est faisable et
vox à son enseigne en a qui s qui avait
déjà est-ce que c'était d'aider des
communautés qui étaient proches des
centres urbains pour qu'ils puissent
continuer de faire ça pour que ça soit
équilibre pour que ce soit à faire
recenser d'une certaine façon parce que
les autres communautés celles les moins
recensés en fait c'est assez récent dans
l'histoire que les benêts qui n'est plus
utilisé dans l'espace public le la seule
façon qui est utilisé en séance publique
c'est des gens qui sort un petit peu de
cas de la connaît depuis un peu d'
affichage discret mais sinon jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle la majorité la très
grande majorité pendant 95 % des abonnés
qui parle abénakis c'est la génération
suivante ensuite qui on regarde la
récente et repartent en 1911
pratiquement tout le monde parle visages
sont trilingues la plupart donc parle
français anglais benaki puis là c'est la
villa qui qui va disparaître
graduellement
20e siècle ça va se faire graduellement
parce qu'avant l'école était en abénakis
puis certains sont allés au pensionnat
donc surtout ceux qui étaient
anglophones sont allés au pensionnat
dont peu ont perdu évidemment l'usagé de
leur langue à travers ce mais la
majorité ne sont pas allés aux
passionnés sont allés à l'école sur
place sauf que l'enseigné soit en
français et en anglais donc la black été
chassés de l'espace public par l'école
aujourd'hui parce que d'ailleurs gabriel
ou même chance a été votre cas quand
vous étiez à l'école primaire vous avez
appris ligne ou sur les bancs de classe
oui sauf ça ce n'est pas la langue
courante utilisée à l'école on avait
quelques cours faisaient partie du
cursus d'accord scolaire mais c'était
pas la langue utilisée pour
l'enseignement
ok seulement quelques courses les
premières années du primaire n'était pas
comme nous alors bon north bay avait il
ya un programme
qui existaient à l'époque s'appelait
être nanou c'est les années de
maternelle se faisaient en immersion en
innu pas que je suis pas au courant je
suis pas certain si ce programme existe
toujours mais je sais que jadis il y
avait la possibilité de faire soigner
parce que je vois chez les attikameks on
enseigne la langue attikameks dans les
premières années du primaire ensuite on
passe aux français mais au moins on a
une base déjà chez les abénakis ça se
fait pas comme ça regarde plus du tout
l'école primaire et pas sur la réserve
danak non plus donc le fait de pouvoir
transmettre des plus complexes à ce
moment le louis forzy de la maman aussi
parce que les jeunes les jeunes qui
semblent des écoles non autochtone c'est
ça oui merci vous pouvoir vous en est
devenu a dit nous de moi je fais partie
d'un projet depuis ça fait presque deux
ans qui s'appelle chanson rassembleuse
negima moutons dans cet effet d'ailleurs
le pour wii à quelques reprises pour ce
projet là puis en fait c'est une
initiative commune du festival de
petite-vallée en gaspésie puis du
festival in common que ceux sur la
côte-nord qui réunissent en fait il qu'à
partir non autochtone pour moi quatre
artistes autochtones dont trois ans de
man utd
oui il y en a 10 km de manawan c'est
vrai puis dans le fond de piolenc s'est
réuni à quelques reprises soit pour
écrire des chansons ensemble en fait des
chansons qui doit être virée country la
jungle oui
donc c'est ça la chanson est vraiment un
prétexte pour ce pour se connaître pour
une re fait une chose s'est cassé en
fait sens à des spectacles depuis depuis
un an et demi puis en fait ils ce projet
qui m'a vraiment donné le goût
d'apprendre comprendre ce que je
chantais comprendre mes nouveaux amis
aussi parce que là on sait ça on se
découvrir mutuellement puis j'avais vu
dans la foulée de ce projet le
documentaire l'empruntent
qui est animé par un hippie ou il
intéresse à l'influencé c'est de prendre
les premières nations dans les
différentes inscriptions au moderne
aujourd'hui puis à plein d'hypothèses
qui sont super intéressante
puis un moment donné rully parlé avec
joséphine bacon puis il disait aussi si
je parle est un outil qu'est ce que je
fais ce que je comprendrais de la
culture que je sais pas maintenant
pyrite c'est à situe parmi nous je me
poserai pas cette question de comprendre
et c'est là que j'ai décidé de faire les
démarches pour eux pour apprendre est ce
que vous trouvez ça difficile ben oui
puis non
c'est ce qu'est ce que c'est tout un
vocabulaire
j'ai comme moi je voudrais pas que je
trouve ça abusé dans leurs prix très
longtemps attendu maintenu je sais que
si je dis bien en tout cas ça faisait
partie nos conversations mais
lorsqu'elle est nerveuse je trouve ça
bien c'est tout un vocabulaire puis des
nouveaux fallait monter à apprendre fait
qu au début tu pas peur de rien fait que
par exemple mais tant pis me méfie c'est
comme la grèce mais là ça faut que tu le
saches sais que tu l'apprends barker
mais après ça quand tu vois le môme et
on copie moonwatch qui veut dire le
cuisinier mais tu peux dire pis mis le
top féminin ok comme le verbe cuisiner
mais là ça fait 10 ans était avec la
grèce puis quand tu vois le kop et le
reste à la fin tu sais que c'est celui
qui fait quelque chose accord avec le
mot que larbins compliqué finalement il
peut si compliqué que ça fait beaucoup
de sens devrait beaucoup mais si mme
lang a great in en fait le triplé
quand tu connais les différents radicaux
puis les accords de verbes sa vie de
plus en plus c'est super imagi com com
comment
est ce qu'au niveau de la benetton nous
rejoindre ce genre 2 et c'est une langue
algonquine donc celles au questionnement
toi en tant qu'autochtones dessus là la
question cavale depuis à poser joséphine
est ce que tu je ressens le besoin de la
pose est ce que tu qu'on est ce que tu
as l'impression d'avoir une relation
avec le territoire avec l'avant j'ai
l'impression à travers la lande de
pouvoir voir des choses que je pourrais
pas voir autrement capables de voir par
exemple le vocabulaire et d'employés je
prends ton temps la formation des verbes
dans certains verbes de par leur
composition on peut retrouver comment
les gens pensent et comment ils
s'expriment est passé des choses qu'on
sait comme sévère bouron l'expriment les
gens vont le voir avec cette forme de
voir les gens vont le voir et d'autres
vers bon ça va être carrément quelque
chose qui est intériorisée puis on peut
comme ceux de les catégoriser puis voir
comment les gens se comportaient
littéralement même si personne parle on
peut voir ce pays même au delà pour une
relation territoire je peux faire je
peux fabriquer certaines choses parce
que je sais chez certains mots puis
leurs compositions dans leur composition
comme l expliquait il mais je dois être
capable de trouver un lien avec un objet
par exemple
selon l'employé pour la construction de
canon je prends un exemple comme cela
les gens vont dire est en face on dirait
de la boîte ap whatever works puis
what's up c'est de la racine d'épinette
blanche
moi je sais que ça prend de la hauteur
je sais bien que larges sièges moldavie
mais je capable de la battre a pas que
la montre et où la même chose pour des
raquettes l'arbre qui sape pour les
raquettes vote dans le mouv à paraître
demain on voit des choses apparaître
comme ça que je serai pas autrement ou
pour les saisons site les saisons nous
sommes assez janvier février
on ne sait pas trop en les disant cette
douce aviez mais non ils nous les
saisons comme étant
avril c'est chiche est payant mais ça
fait c'est le mois des gibiers d'eau de
l'affiché place pelletan louise oiseaux
car il après ça le mois 2 le mois de
voyants de ou blessé ou pas au pays en
place et les petits oiseaux qui porte
une parole juste en sachant qu'ils
présentent déjà tu apprends des choses
sur la nature oui oui ça c'est drôlement
intéressant parce que justement ça nous
ramène au territoire ça nous ramène là
dans la nature
grâce à tous ces termes utilisés là
gabriel
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de vous
réapproprier votre langue parce que on
dit 2019 l'année des langues autochtones
il ya beaucoup d'autochtones qui ne
reprennent pas leur langue ou qui ne la
connaissent pas qui n'ont pas envie de
la prendre mais j'ai que pendant mon
enfance a toujours été un acquis pour
moi d'apprendre nous parce que c'était
ce que ce qu'on faisait à l'école de la
maternelle jusqu'au secondaire 5 et
c'est ce que je faisais donc c'était moi
c'était c'est inné de le faire c'est pas
quelque chose que je que je pense de mon
plein gré on me le montrer à l'école
donc c'était quelque chose que je ne
pensais pas vraiment beaucoup à ça mais
je savais que c'était important de le
faire mais je le faisais s'en trouve on
trouve questionner mais en quittant
m'acheter as puis en aménageant montréal
si je me suis rendu compte un peu que ça
représentait un peu plus on est en haut
de la communauté puis en pratique en
plus du tout la langue
j'ai comme sanction un certain sentiment
d'urgence de devoir le refaire
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
m'inscrire en cours à l'université avec
avec idem en haleine donc j'ai pris le
cours des débutants même si
là bas ce que j'ai déjà parce que mais
je pense que c'est important de leur
pratique est toujours un peu plus nos
connaissances regagne les jeunes mais
surtout parce que ça faisait déjà
plusieurs années que je pratiquais plus
donc vu de certaines notions que j'ai
perdu surtout pour la construction de
phrase les verbes c'est toujours quelque
chose qui était à retravailler pour moi
mais donc c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
de quand vous allez dans la communauté
même chose pour vous charles est ce que
les gens autour de vous par lynn ou si
vous avez de l'entente moi ce que je
connais ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai vu
comme statistiques y avait 33 % la
communauté qui parle parle parle il nous
n'a la communauté hellénique
oui donc les jeunes en étant on t'en va
pas vous dirais qu'avec l'accord avec la
ville de roberval on voit l'école à
roberval ya des écoles aussi d'amasser
cammas theolia et c'est ça dans ma
famille personne qui parlez nous du côté
de mon du côté de ma mère est du côté de
mon père ma grand-mère et ses
descendants de ces enfants que ça me
parle pas donc ma grand mère est décédée
donc plus personne qui peut la prendre à
partir de direct de la famille dirige
donc c'est vraiment les années qui qui
porte ce savoir la vendée avec la
situation un match est différent de la
situation dans les autres communautés et
nous on est un peu isolé je dirais de
détresse des autres communautés qui sont
tous sur la côte nord est sur la côte
nord font partie n'étaient qu'à pêche
qui réagit un peu la langue innu labeouf
qui nous ont fait pas partie de ceux là
façon dont on apprend la façon dont on
parle est différente aussi de ski de ce
qui se fait sur la coupe non mais on
veut ça se comprend quand même quand il
y est tu me donnes s'encourage le
comprend les mots qu'elle dit même s'ils
sont dix alec évidemment très différent
de ce que j'ai appris quand j'étais à
l'école accord parce que je voyais innu
environ 11000 locuteurs de ces c'est
surtout la lacaune en jeu ben mouaïa
beaucoup de sous pour beaucoup la bosse
et leur langue leur première utilise
dans l' usage courant de tous les jours
mais alors pour vous deux est ce qu'il
ya une urgence lorsque vous la sentez
l'urgence de vous réapproprier rome ou
non pour une agence culturelle oui
jean une nécessité personnelle non pas
pour moi mais si je sens que je sais
c'est une partie la culture que je veux
que je veux partager
je vais devoir la prendre enfin comédien
belge
j'ai la chance va pouvoir le faire oui
je vous en parlais dans ma chronique
alors que vous gabriel vous vous êtes
journaliste et vous allez continuer je
pense dans cette voie là est-ce que ça
va vous servir
j'espère le sujet a travaillé dans les
communautés les autres communautés nous
c'est sûr que c'est ça permet de
comprendre vraiment le contexte dans
lequel le évolué c'est sûr que même un
niveau personnel c'est quelque chose que
je veux que je veux développer en voyant
des amis que j'ai d'autres communautés
qui eux parlent leur langue couramment
et qu'il utilise je me sens un peu je me
sens un peu à part j'aimerais ça pour
faire dire que je fais partie de soi
aussi
yvette molunes l'enseigne ici en région
urbaine donc à montréal mais est-ce que
si on va sur la côte nord est ce que si
on va au saguenay-lac-saint-jean est ce
qu'il ya des cours dit nous une femme
qui en a l université de ce couple uni
depuis cette année ça s'arrête
je vois ça je suis pas certaine de sa
non plus parce que même dans les cours
ici à montréal il ya pas beaucoup de toc
tonnes dans les cours que ce soit même
dean hood abénakis là il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'inscrits non c'est pas des
très grands groupes de toute façon pour
des cours de langue c'est mieux de pas
avoir 35 personnes
l'universel montréal vous êtes une
trentaine dans vos classes
ouais ouais à peu près entre 2,20 et
mettant la connaissance à moi on était
peut-être un peu plus nous sommes mieux
quand même
quand même demande oui des gens qui
finissent leur bac aussi évidemment les
non autochtones le fond peut-être pour
des raisons professionnelles parce
qu'ils vont aller travailler dans les
communautés mais les non autochtones
je veux dire les autochtones est-ce
qu'ils le suivent parce qu'ils sont
persévérants est-ce qu'ils vont
jusqu'aux roues justement pour toutes
ces raisons là de réappropriation sa
langue est ce que le voyez chez les
abénakis bâches des groupes je prédis
mixad des abénakis et des noms avaient
naquit qui sont dans mes classes à peu
près égales le pourcentage est bas ces
gens là ont des motivations souvent
assez diverses mais souvent simples de
la la réappropriation de leur propre
culture
cette averse évidemment apprendre une
langue c'est pas toujours évident dans
un contexte on ne vit à dans votre
travail il faut consacrer du temps passe
et ceux qui prônent le oui merci ni dans
le cours donné par yvette le cours que
vous suivez donc là vous êtes à la
deuxième session
il ya beaucoup d'autochtones en cours
non il y en a peu mais il y en a pas en
fait le premier corps y en avait pas
puis je pense le deuxième et quelques
nouvelles personnes mais non ouais non
plus gagner je suis là c'est le docteur
va classe également
est-ce qu'on devrait s'inquiéter c'est
une bulle c'est une bonne question mais
je pourrais comprendre si dd innu comme
moi décide à les suivre le cours des
événements l'inversé montréal ils vous
réservent aussi des jeux du truc que
j'ai vu je sens pas le besoin c'est de
refaire ça donc ça pourrait être la
raison pourquoi ces gens là ces skiffs
peau assez court l'an passé vraiment des
cours de base bah oui ouais bien dans
des clans à montréal autochtone ou celle
qui priorise les autochtones et la
beauté la main une grande diversité de
langues
c'est vrai alors il ya plusieurs langues
qui vivent des moments difficiles et il
y en a d'autres ont dit qu'ils sont
quand même plus vivante c'est le cas de
ligne petit tout ça fait partie
d'ailleurs des trois langues autochtones
n'est plus les plus fortes le krill
hibou et elin outil tout est voué liche
vous suivait des cours dit nos petites
ou donc vous le dit depuis que vous
travaillez à regard sur l'arctique
oui dans vos classes des autochtones ou
non mais moi j'ai une peu le même défi
que vous avez eue c'était que de
chercher des cours ou un prof ça me puis
des années j'ai fait beaucoup moins même
avec des ressources si on a le temps
plus tard de parler des ressources
souligne que j'ai trouvé mais le corps
ici à montréal avec le centre culturel
pour les 1/8
ici il ya une preuve que georges feydeau
tu as qui est très connu dans le milieu
à une quinzaine de petits tubes s'agit
suit les colas ils sont pas toujours à
faire part quand il de nouveau mais
après ça il n'y a pas grand chose à
faire c'est un booster de reprendre le
cours après une heure ou deux ans et
puis c'est le il y beaucoup de demandes
mais c'est le difficultés avec la langue
inuit c'est qu'il ya plusieurs dialectes
au canada plusieurs
et puis à cause de ça pour chaque aux
séquelles direct qu'on va apprendre et
si on apprend par exemple
d'une petite route de nunavik si on veut
nous de vous la présenter problème aussi
sur le manque de matériaux pour enseigne
la langue
un défi mais en disant ça avec nos
petits trucs comme vous avez dit si l'un
d'eux les langues autochtones au canada
de plus en santé alors il ya plus de
ressources que pour d'autres langues
mais dit d'autres partis par exemple les
inuits du labrador
le lendemain aux inuit là c'est en
danger d'extinction malheureusement leur
dialecte
alors c'est une porte rien pour
différents dans l'arctique
vous dites qu'il y en a de moins en
moins pourquoi pas ce qu'il ya de moins
en moins de locuteurs là encore si les
pernois si on voit par exemple l'île de
batz fin aux mines au goût de la langue
la langue inuit et en santé ce
extraordinaire les enfants jouent dans
la langue inuit
c'est ça les gens parlent comme dans la
langue de tous les jours
par contre au labrador se tiennent de la
première classe inuit au canada d'être
colonisés alors c'est juste l'érosion de
la culture et la langue et maintenant
les deux derniers sangsues sont pas
maintenant juste quelques centaines de
personnes nous la perdons les inuits qui
parlent la langue inuit comme langue
maternelle
alors c'est pour ça c'est une profession
peu difficile à mai au musée vous si on
ne vit que c'est collectivement en santé
oui et au nunavut d'ailleurs on fait des
efforts particuliers surtout en cette
année internationale des langues
autochtones je lisais que on espère que
le gouvernement va reconnaître les
outils tout comme la langue fondatrice
du territoire oui et c'est le dixième
anniversaire de la loi sur la protection
de langue inuit au nunavut est vaste et
le pressage cette année avec une grande
conférence pour parler de tout ça est ce
que la loi a fait il ya dix ans ils ont
mis la langue inuit au même pied que
l'anglais au français
ce ça veut dire que les gens qui vivent
au nunavut is on doit au service du
gouvernement en inaptitude mais aussi
des services santé et aussi des services
d'urgence alors ça c'est une succès qui
veut marquer mais aussi il va prendre
cette conférence aussi de voir les défis
qui restent est une chose qui est
prioritaire qui préoccupe les gens le
nouveau c'est le manque d enseignante
on a là un menu est oui
c'est un peu comme lors des autres loin
alors sortis du lot et le rêve c'est de
pouvoir offrir l'éducation en langue
inuit aux gens du nunavut jusqu'à sa
candeur 5 mais sont loin de ça
malheureusement maintenance à ces défis
qui restent mais il est beaucoup nous
ont marqués juste avec cette législation
d'avoir langue autochtone au même pied
avec l'anglais francis ces religions
après la conférence est sera pas donnée
en inaptitude à oui mais je pense que
wang beaucoup de beaucoup de locuteurs
dino petit août seront là pour pour en
parler après 10 ans d'apprentissage de
la langue est un outil tout vous êtes
avancer ou pas moi je dirai ce départ
les difficultés encore c'est comme par
exemple quand je pars en reportage je
suis dans un an peut néanmoins se bat
bien et je veux jamais être capable de
parler de la politique ou la science en
anglais 8 mai juste à voir les
interactions de tous les jours avec les
gens pour moi c'est très très important
mais la chose la plus important et même
si on peut pas s'exprimer couramment
c'est d'être comprendre la façon de
penser c'est tellement important avec je
pense que mon travail je fais de mieux
un meilleur travail dans le nord parce
que c'est juste comprendre la façon que
les gens pensent ses pieds de façon
qu'ils voient le monde
oui anne alors cessé pour cesser c'est
très beau mais encore avec les
différences de dialectes c'est très
difficile ici à montréal de comme
maintenir la langue et de parler de surf
plus rudement bien sûr quand il est pas
tout les ressources
est ce qu'une orthographe ce qu'ils sont
la risée pour tous les dialectes quand
même nom mairie il ya les aveux betts en
défaisant la façon des milieux
différents et ça c'est une gros des vols
dans le monde et nous et maintenant pas
juste au canada mais avec les inuits en
russie au groenland et en alaska
parce qu'il se demande si on est ou
langnau et standardisée internationale
ce nous donnerait une puissance
politique on peut publier les livres le
matériau pour l'éducation permanente de
certaines communautés le fonds qu'il
savait des choses
mais exactement cinéma là parce que
exemple les inuits deux labradors ils
ont dit oui c'est un projet intéressant
mais notre dialogue c'est vraiment dans
une génération reste à voir nos
dialectes complément est distincte
est-ce qu'on peut mettre les ressources
pour travailler sur le projet comme ça
quand notre directeur en péril
maintenant ce sont des bonnes dans la
communauté web des années alors depuis
qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir justin
trudeau a dit qu'il avait l'intention de
déposer un projet de loi sur la
protection et la rue vitalisation des
langues autochtones
à l'automne nous seront en élection
fédérale
avez vous l'impression que ce projet de
loi va être déposé ce qu'il ya vraiment
une envie profonde de réaliser ce projet
de loi la question se pose un serment
est ce que la loi va déposer pas déposé
ses on a beau déposer une loi à ce que
les fonds vont venir avec qu'est-ce
qu'il aura de l'argent parce que déjà
c'est une première étape quand même mais
oui c'est simple c'est la question parce
que ce soit pour les langues pour la
plupart des landes
comment le tuteur c'est c'est une
question est-ce qu assez d'enseignants
justement pour transmettre la langue
mais pour avoir des enseignants
il faut les payer il faut qu'elle ait du
temps par exemple je prends mon cas
personnel
là je fais ça à temps plein mais est-ce
que ça va me permettre de vivre à long
terme
ça me souhaite le dilemme de toutes les
professeurs de langue autochtone c'est
les fonds puis pour préserver une langue
justement caillou pas de matériel
pédagogique bas il faut en fabriquer ça
prend des fonds aussi donc ça on a beau
devenait en plénière c'est l'argent
c'est l'argent parce que pour
revitaliser c'est la seule façon de le
faire c'est par l'enseignement parce
allait lancer son prix voilà puis ça
prend du budget pour faire matériel pour
les enseignants c'est là que ça va jouer
c'est plus l'enjeu est ce que vous avez
espoir s attend des vents bat jeu
je rapportais à dire que souvent on crie
fort mais se passe pas grand chose là
les seules étapes convoi par etc on crie
très fort
les budgets ce qui sont là je pousserai
portait à croire que ça va prendre un
plus grand effort de souci on veut
vraiment leur rêve d'élise et ça va
prendre beaucoup plus question est ce
que le fait qu'on va peut-être un invité
des traducteurs au parlement canadien
pour les gens qui vont s'exprimer dans
les langues autochtones ce serait déjà
un pas vers une reconnaissance d'être un
pilote sauce faut se méfier parce que
partenaires je vais prendre un exemple
chez lui au mois de novembre
rassemblement langues et cultures
d'automne sur pn et là il y avait un
éventail de gens qui enseigne les
langues pendant que les gens sont lime
conseil en éducation des travaillant à
son saut
les gens qui étaient là romain ans c est
cette journée là ces deux journées une
enseigne pas donc sans un traducteur il
va se consacrer un texte on va les en a
vingt partants il fait pas d'autre chose
pour diane sont en péril
comme par exemple la bd qui je pourrais
prendre l'exemple abénakis qu'à peu près
trois personnes qui sont qu'avec
d'autres atouts de korité qui même le
salon leur prendre un certain et un
train dans le texte va être lieu bar ils
vont consacrer une semaine deux semaines
prenons l'exemple si c'est moi je prends
je retombe à moindre frais tandis que
l'autre où il vous faudra consacrer un
certain temps à traduire le texte
pendant tant de gens 5 pouces donc on va
prendre quelqu'un qui en cinq ans madame
pascale intéresse votre adjoint d'aix et
le texte a ensuite bien on relit rice
avait terminé mais la personne grâce à
leur appareil pendant une semaine deux
semaines pour faire ça donc c'est
prendre des ressources les déplacer ça
va être beau on ramène un espace public
mais est ce que c'est vraiment ce qu'on
veut de l'enap terrible comme souvent
fait ça va attirer des gens qu'on voit
ça ça peut être un docu pourrait avoir
un autre fignon moi je pense et on aura
des traducteurs pour toutes les langues
des gens des choses dans notre propre la
question ce proverbe même pour d'autres
langues parce que quand même déplacé les
gencives hathaway il faut te placer la
personne sa part je peux dans le fin
fond du nunavut
la personne peut qu'apprendre
invraisemblable est reparti plusieurs
jours si la personne est un enseignant
déjà il ya des traducteurs
professionnels on se déplacer pendant ce
temps le font pas ou trois jours si on
prend un enseignant
by en cinq pots par l'apd est une somme
record d'occupants on est en train de
documenter les langues présentement donc
si advenant qu'on perd une langue
il va avoir déjà plus de documentation
qui en avait qu'un en reste avec la peña
qui déjà à l'époque donc aucune
possibilité de pouvoir la faire revivre
éventuellement ou quelque chose mais les
bus est certain de ne pas la perdre
c'est la base
je vais te mettre les ressources au bon
endroit dépassé par ces taxes qui est
lue devant la chambre des communes
c'est intéressant ça fait un texte est
ce que c'est la meilleure façon
d'investir pour l'instant les ressources
la question que je me pose la question
se pose en effet marc si vous faites de
l'appropriation de la langue il nous
parlera charles vous voulez faire de la
réappropriation de la langue par là
exactement
en fait en jeu montrer comment les liens
qu'on offre comme artiste entre le la
langue et la caisse que qu'est ce que
l'art est un langage on sait que on sait
que la langue était est au centre de la
culture des premières nations le réalité
tout ça donc on sait que c'est tout est
formée autour de se mouiller geoffrey a
soudain temps les autochtones ont
toujours été payés avec les français les
anglais avec leur parler français ou
anglais avec leurs propres langues dont
c'est difficile d'assimiler des concepts
linguistique assez rapidement quand les
premiers colons sont arrivés tout ça
donc commun qu'on discute comment qu'on
communique
comment qu'on le fait exemple les
autochtones ont toujours été d'un bambin
dans l'art d'une certaine façon par
exemple le ou bentley la danse du
cerceau qui était une danse pour
raconter une histoire qui sont là pour
pour discuter avec les autres nations
quand ils se rencontrent et il le
faisait il le faisait l'art par là par
la danse moins que c'est une forme de
communication
on regarde j'ai une photo pour une photo
à vous envoyer à pouvoir garder cette
photo david garneau qui est inquiétante
qui est une toile en fait à l'huile
représente vraiment les deux différentes
pensée entre autochtones et non
autochtones comment qu'on fait pour
essayer de se comprendre comment compte
vers quoi qu'on s'en va c'est quoi la
possibilité donc c'est le one paul le
guen pomme qui est une oeuvre d'art
extraordinaire mais qui a un sens qui a
un sens politique qui est vraiment rien
à voir avec la grande ceinture permet en
fait ils optent pour remercier pour un
traité pour pour eux souligné entraîné
donc voilà oui et on utilise là pour
communiquer depuis toujours je crois en
un collecteur et comment qu'on fait pour
se réapproprier aujourd'hui notre langue
exemple par la mouette un comédien je
veux pas je veux partager ma langue je
je pouvoir la faire en temps aux autres
comment je les fais je dois rencontrer
yvette écrire un texte en français
yvette ont peu dessus on peux-tu faire
la modification le par la traduction de
ce texte là pour que je puisse le dire
le mettre dans mes mots pouvoir le leur
a conté en fête donc cette traduction là
qu'il vienne cet apprentissage la de la
langue
cette mise en bouche de la langue qui se
fait de ma part donc pour moi il ya un
certain apprentissage est aussi pour les
artistes maintenant une expulsion
simplement de donner un nom autochtone
at-on exposition là ça va donner déjà
une possibilité on veut faire on va
faire lire le message envoyé de faire
comprendre la prononciation et donc
comme mouliets qui vise à montréal oui
c'est vrai je les fais référence
justement un moule ya tout il ya
quelques mots d'ailleurs en innu qui
sont prononcés alors c'est sûr que pour
les gens dans la salle c'est déjà une
première incursion mais bon elle est
vraiment minime là il faut aussi
intéressé ensuite pour aller plus loin
que ça et c'est souvent ça la difficulté
un d'aller au delà de ça
au delà d'une première incursion une
première ouverture vers vers la dent
c'est gênant c'est gênant aussi des fois
d'arriver ça peut être ça peut être ça
peut être long ça peut être lourd à
porter d'arrivée de 20
vent devant des gens que tu connais qui
parlent la langue et de la parler et de
la baragouiner qu'on pourrait dire et
mais c'est là que ça donne ça donne le
goût de faire l'effort d'essayer de la
prendre davantage de biens la prononcer
d'être juste dans tes dents tu es dans
tes dires en fait donc cesser c'est de
ce côté là aussi
moi j'ai remarqué un moment donné il ya
marco koninck et comédien qui avec
elle-même part seul en nous à faire dans
une pièce de théâtre et et l affaire
ramasse tes mouillage puis les gens ont
trouvé intéressant de voir ça de voir ce
travail là qui a été fait un ok ils ne
parlent pas mais on fait l'effort de
faire en tant que comédien d'essayer
d'aller chercher cette vérité là donc
donc je pense qu'en tant qu'artiste
c'est plus facile de se réapproprier
parce qu'on veut là on veut la partager
on veut la faire on veut la faire
découvrir par le biais neutre à mais
souvent aussi à des artistes comme des
artistes sont pas intéressés à vouloir
la parler ou la communiquer donc ils
vont y aller par le chef vont aller dans
une des dards autochtone il ya des gens
qui vont aller dans ma sphère de la
avait aucune connotation autochtone donc
une possibilité on va voir comment ça va
se développer d'ailleurs au cours de la
prochaine année vous comme c'est l'année
des longues se tenait ce qui est des des
programmes spécial qui vont être
présentés est ce que vous allez faire
des activités particulières est ce que
je peux entendre n'est prévu à ce niveau
là je pensais plus si hâtive l'échelle
planétaire
oui mais personnellement j'ai projet
pose bien sûr j'ai pas vu l'application
ce niveau le chili votre espoir en tout
cas pour la langue abénakis puisque
c'est celle que vous enseignez que vous
connaissez quand vous regardez l'avenir
avez vous espoir que quelqu'un va
prendre la relève
votre relève éventuellement pour
l'enseigné entre autres ben en fait le
l'espoir est écrit par le collège qui
honore parce que souvent je leur marque
en enseignant c'est ça prend une
assiduité certaine ce soit la question
de la carotte et du bâton il le fait
d'avoir des notes associé à
l'enseignement
on suit des cours donc on note puis on
repère savard a traversé les trois
personnes présentes mais qui sur deco ça
va ça va c'est bien au delà de mes
attentes pour aider mais elle vraiment
l'espoir est créée par le fait que c'est
institutionnalisé c'est à dire que le
sénat sur la carte scolaire des gens
vient de s'asseoir étudie on dénote et
en conséquence de ce sommet au bout de
deux ans vont peut-être avoir un diplôme
par une bonne cadence d'alang peut-être
voilà transmis depuis l'aube à aquio
n'at il ya trois langues donc l'ati km
il ya là benaki pioline nuit donc c'est
la première fois que programmes ont pour
collégial où il y au lancement des
grands prix pendant deux ans parce que
là il ya des cours candidats comme nico
vous suivez à l'université on est des
cons comme se mêlent les personnes après
sont obligés de continuer le dans un
procès de deux êtres amiable cours des
tout petits de continuer évidemment au
bout du compte soit une certaine
connaissance puisse citer tassilo c'est
que ça t'intéresse donc il ya de
l'espoir parce que c'est maintenant la
grâce au collège qu'une je prédis que le
lion une avance main pour au moins trois
langues
merci vous commencez votre deuxième
session mais vous allez vous allez
jusqu'au bout
oui un des trois cartes le prévoit et
contenait encore puis oui oui vraiment
là j'essaie de comprendre de plus en
plus le gérer les poèmes de joséphine
bacon me sens comme si offre en français
pierre unis toujours le langage la
partie en français plus ok j'ai une
bonne et de l'ana je ne sais pas mais
que cet homme important fait que leur
quart alors que ça représente de plus en
plus dans l'espace public que ça se
passe de plus en plus mais c'est ce qu'
elle qui donne la curiosité de
l'apprendre cité souvent va se décider
dans un anglais à d'apprendre royal ou
pas ce qu'on entend une chanson parce
qu'on a parce qu'on a l'impression de
manquer quelque chose si on la prend peu
puis mais on manque c'est très sain pour
avoir cette impression quand vous dites
à vos amis que vous étudiez les
nouvelles on vous prend pour redéfinir
d'après les notes screen peut-être les
homos
oui mais si souvent mais je me fais de
demander pourquoi et tout mais c'est ça
avec eux avec le projet de musique ça
fait dix ans puis mais la chanson ça est
aussi beaucoup à apprendre et monte à
les apprendre par coeur à se dépasser en
tête mais j'ai acheté des livres pour
enfants s'il dit tout cela tourne dans
le territoire
mais c'est vraiment à la fois en
neuvième mais j'ai ouï pouvoir
comprendre mieux affecter de
conversation un peu alors gabriel et à
côté oui gabriel quand vous dites à
votre communauté à vos parents que vous
étudiez les new line ou bas ils le
savent de toute façon mais comment
est-ce que réagit c'est quoi ben ma
famille était vraiment content quand je
leur ai dit que j'avais pris un cours
dit nos universités puis c'était
vraiment très enthousiasmés par par
cette initiative que j'ai prise donc ma
mallette est très fier allez-vous de
l'espoir que la langue va va continuer
de vivre
j'espère moi je dois vous êtes l'agent
général en appelle donc vous voyez
l'avenir à plus long terme et moi je
bois beaucoup d'espoir le quand je
regarde avec hussein un groupe d'amis
les jeunes qui sont venues avec moi à
l'école amassé h
on a tous cet été les lieux de vouloir
réapprenez de vouloir se réapproprier
notre langue notre culture
non moi je vois beaucoup d'espoir de la
dame qui chaussures que on va être des
parents qui vont transmettre cet amour
là aussi da culture et la langue à nos
enfants donc moi moi j'ai espoir oui
charles votre prochain rôle en innu sait
quand et où ben je sais pas on va voir
j'ai pas encore de choses qui s'en vient
on va attendre ce qui se présente à moi
mais c'est ça en parlant de rôle
c'est toujours un j'avais un petit un
petit conseil à faire ou aux scénaristes
qu'à côté on voit beaucoup ça tient un
petit ex allié à faire les parrains
autochtones qui ont eu des fois on
retrouve des démons autochtone de dames
et on retrouve plus qu'un dialecte on
retrouve qu'à deux dialectes à du moca
de l'algonquin et de line ou dans les
algues ont cessé l'on vient tout
mélanger on veut que ça soit interprétée
par une seule nation donc la cale nation
au dessus je pense que c'est de ce souci
de ce petit détail la d'aller voir si si
si le personnage du texte est un une
lettre ou un nid nous de faire la
différence quand qu'on va chercher le
comédien je pense que ça pourrait aider
et surtout surtout au niveau de la
prononciation
moi je parle pas le moral j'ai plus de
facilité à prononcer ni nous mais si tu
me demandes apprenons aussi du mois que
ça va être plus difficile pour moi
voilà hellich les cours dit nos petits
tout vous en suivez depuis dix ans vous
comptez ensuite pendant encore combien
d'années avant vraiment de nathan miller
feu nouveau poids d'un avatar mais je
veux juste souligner deux choses une
site web qui se parlent juste langues
et puis c'est un site web génial pour
apprendre la langue inuit s'est il parle
juste les dialectes du neveu mais je
recommande toutes les personnes envoient
un l'image la voilà et puis les
explications sont en français et on peut
même choisir le deal aig qu'on veut
apprendre et tu relis d'ilog les
explications ça va être dense et
dialectes et puis le 2e saut je peux pas
terminer sans mentionner le nom twitter
dingue
henderson je sais pas si on va voir son
compte sur l'écran mary j lui et les
hommes inouk au labrador oui on a parlé
de dialectes l'acquis en péril la le
voyant oui c'est lui et chaque journée
mr henderson il va faire une truite avec
le mot du jour avec la prononciation et
puis le cycle efficace dans le dialecte
du labrador
ce jeu c'est vraiment c'est génial et
puis
envoie le syli pâques j'ai pas mes
lunettes mais chaque journée et c'est
trés façon d'enrichir le vocabulaire ou
à chaque jour et puis les personnes avec
beaucoup d'humour soja commandeur son
compte twitter aussi la cour me nakache
au leone et philippe et jean hache comme
it in the name of ça va très vite
jusqu'au meeting
merci à tous gracias thank you est
vraiment merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à cette table ronde sur les
langues autochtones et on va y revenir
de toute façon au cours de l'année et
merci à vous et évidemment d'avoir
participé à cette première édition d'
espace autochtone en direct rendez vous
vendredi prochain à 12h15 au revoir
[Musique]